[Music]
in india you have seven hundred thousand
villages
and each village has at least two or
three bands there is no marriage without
a band there is no death without a ban
there is no birth without a ban
and bands they need instruments
roughly 90 percent of india's brass band
instruments come from this musical alley
jalikoti lane in the city of meerut
very kodi lane has about 100
manufacturers
but one of the most renowned is nadir
ali company
mr nader who was my uncle started this
company in 1885.
he was the first man who started a band
in india he raised the first band in
1900 with 24 people
it was immensely lagged by the indian
people
and his uncle wasn't the only one with a
passion for the family business
my father's father my father myself and
now my children so you can say the
fourth generation is here
we make brass band musical instruments
like trumpets coordinates ephonium cuba
and also percussion instruments like
drums and things like that
you see in instrument making is an art
our instruments are the best because we
use a system of quality control
the most important thing in making an
instrument is the composition of brass
the material quality
the instruments from here go to many
countries
anywhere from saudi arabia to germany to
france
i have devoted my life in making
instruments
music is the elixir of life when you
play and you you concentrate and you
play a good tune or you hear a good tune
you think you are out of this world
music is something but you listen to it
and you're lost
and you're happy
[Music]
you